the effects of climate change happen
fastest in the Arctic here Wetlands
forests permafrost unique species and
Indigenous peoples live face to face
with the direct impacts of our warming
Planet scientists have monitored the
Arctic for Generations but after the
start of the war in Ukraine
collaborations froze data streams built
up for years went quiet as Nations and
universities ceased Partnerships with
counterparts in Russia the effects on
science were immediate one of the most
concerning data streams that we have
lost is real time or near real-time
observations of atmospheric greenhouse
gas concentrations from from towers that
are placed across Siberia interact a
European network runs 89 collaborative
Arctic monitoring stations 21 across
Russia lost funding After the War Began
information that can only be gathered on
the ground is already being lost we
can't understand planet Earth without
understanding the Arctic because in the
Arctic we have what they call positive
feedbacks that when we stir up something
in the Arctic because of fossil fuel
emissions from the rest of the world
then a chain of event happens in the
Arctic but those events don't stay there
there's an amplification of climate
change which happens in the rest of the
world
the Sami Council represents indigenous
peoples across four countries including
Russia it suspended funding its Russian
Representatives while maintaining
scientific research the larger scale
monitoring is important but as
indigenous peoples in the Arctic we have
embedded in our culture it's a long-term
monitoring on a more local and Regional
scale over the Millennials have been
living in these areas we have
accumulated a lot of of uh monitoring
data to put it that way which is
embedded in our indigenous languages
the Arctic is warming fast the full
costs of the data loss may not be known
for some time Colin Baker Al Jazeera